yeah so just to give context I first
started write like reading about sensor
flow not not right away yeah these guys
are the early adopters they're like
helping contribute few people outside of
Google right like they don't work for
Google yeah which is kind of cool that
they're accepting pull requests yeah so
I started looking I think maybe January
February I pulled down the white paper
and just sat on my hard drive for a
while and knew that there were good
patterns and they're good distributed
patterns that I was reading about but
hadn't yet seen so I was but yeah right
when they came out with tons full
distributed that's where things change
there that's pretty much the big
difference between early tensorflow and
like cafe and Theano and that kind of
stuff is this hold rarely distribution
model because they're all pretty much do
the auto differentiation which we'll
talk stochastic gradient or the gradient
descent all those same things let me
find the presentation that we ok I think
this is also my first talk where I'm not
using PowerPoint so we'll see how this
goes
try the new presentation view okay yeah
Pete can you hear me okay back there all
right yeah we're recording this so yeah
please don't stomp us too much yeah
so first of all I'm gonna get the meetup
updates out of the way yeah I see a lot
of familiar faces this is great you guys
are yeah I've been with me for a while
we'll talk about technology updates that
actually some of them happen this week
kafka point 10 and confluent 3.0 came
out a lot of cool stuff in there of
course spark 200 is still baking but
pulled down early release and I realized
Epling is incompatible with spark 2l so
I have to wait for the Hortonworks slash
or like NF Labs guys to get caught up
there apparently
we'll talk about spark model serving so
this is kind of layer that my new
company flux capacitor is focusing on so
rarely get everyone talks about training
and we're like that whole thing at data
bricks right like that's all we do is
help companies train and but then what
do you do right like where do you put
the model yeah it's actually serve it up
so tensorflow has something called
tensorflow serving i'm building the same
thing but for spark and for the JVM so
we'll talk about the patterns there I'll
show a demo of kind of early stuff we
have I say I'm in stealth but I tell
everyone what I'm working on so it's not
really yeah that effective oh and then
yeah so looks somehow I got the first
four bullet points here but actually
they're gonna be the brunt of the talk
the second and and third thirds will be
about tensorflow
yeah so these guys have a lot of
knowledge about sort of hidden gems
within the rally tends to flow right
like code base things that have not yet
been documented very well people are
kind of wondering so yeah these guys
will help fill in some of those please
ask questions to ask questions as we go
you have the normal thing Fabricio is
trying to get the distributed model or
yeah the tennis pro distributed demo
working it's gonna be pretty demo heavy
we have a surprise demo at the end that
I think is gonna work right Sam
hopefully yeah small device pantent
it's a form of a fruit let's see yeah
we're up to almost 3500 members this is
pretty crazy this is only been going on
for about ten months let's see yeah we
got the LA kid yeah like that's what I
call him Sam I've got the Italian
stallion yeah I'm from Chicago so of
course I love Mike Ditka yeah that was
the Bears 49er game I think the first
game actually at the new stadium I
shaved my mustache it was my beard and
left the mustache for did get purposes
pancake stack I think you guys are all
probably familiar come see the actual
yeah oh yes actually who wants for the
first pancake sack oh oh yeah yeah well
you came in at like 2:00 p.m. and like
didn't even get a server
we give everyone their own Google Cloud
instance at the very end we're gonna
build a huge cluster each each Google
Cloud instance is chosen purposely
because it has a lot of memory I've kind
of given up on doing workshops with
people's laptops it just doesn't work
you spend the first three hours you know
probably debugging or like USB issues
and you know trying to get the USB to
work and all this crap and docker and
everything so it's just easier it's not
the you know cheapest route but each
Google instance has 8 cores 50 gigs of
RAM and 100 gig SSD so we're gonna build
yeah so these two clowns are gonna be
part of the fun on June 4th so not only
will we build a huge 800 core 5 terabyte
spark cluster but same with like
tensorflow distributed yeah and then the
pancake bot yes I bought one of those
recently it was a Kickstarter thing
takes about 45 minutes per pancake but
yeah we have 8 hours together so we can
make about 8 of them the first date this
slide got busier and busier but
technology updates so this is my part
tech update spark - oh we're gonna talk
about that kafka CUDA 8 and then the
CUDA right like neural network the deep
neural network library just came out -
there was a blog post I think even today
or yesterday so version 5 is out yes I'm
curious like when will tensorflow
support it guys do you
yeah has there been any word on the chat
groups
just recently right right yeah the way
we implemented that kind of one of the
guy is working with non GPU but there is
something coming up
yeah yeah the tough part with these
neural networks is storing the state
yeah and I think we'll actually talk
about hello hello hello okay yeah so
we'll talk a little bit about recurrent
neural networks and an LS TM long
short-term memory where during the
forward and then back propagation
there's data being there state being
stored right so obviously this increases
the memory footprint and these GPUs only
have you know 12 gig 16 gig right now
just because of the physical
architecture the hardware architecture
of these things so it's commonly used in
like NLP type things where if you're
right like sort of traversing along a
sentence and storing the current gender
that you found and then you probably
come in and or the if it's plural or not
or you know singular and then once you
come across a new gender you would kick
out the old so just trying to figure out
when you kick things out and when things
stay in this forward and back
propagation loop SPARC 2.0 core yeah a
lot of stuff going on here the coolest
thing is this whole stage code
generation so if you read this from
bottom to top which is how these
physical plans read right any time you
see this kind of tree this took me like
three years to figure out or you always
start at the bottom that move up so
what's happening is there's three so
basically we're fusing together
operators like physically so what's
funny is I go back to you know one of my
first or second spark meetup talks right
like this talk and and right yeah so I
actually thought that this was happening
back then but it's not so what yeah so
what's going on is like they're
physically we're like taking right like
your source code figuring out what
you're trying to do you know here
there's a range and then a filter and
then an aggregation happening so that's
these three so those can physically be
fused into one physical right like Java
right like method basically so
yeah so spark 12 7 9 5 has the gory
details here but basically if you're not
if you have three separate function
calls right there's all these like
virtual function you know call chains
and things like that and then rally
point things like the CPU registers
blowing them away so here it's this
whole stage thing so each stage can now
be collapsed into one physical method
this cannot be fused in because of the
shuffle yeah classic loop unrolling
Cindy cogeneration so basic Oh
so at some point right like mattei who's
the creator of spark right like one of
the main guys behind spark he's at like
MIT right now doing his PhD postdoc or
whatever it's called he has his little
minions that we're working on LLVM it
turns out that if you can sort of give
the rat like the rat like JIT compiler
right like enough info and like right
like big enough batches right like
vectorized batches legit can actually
compile faster code then we're like
handwritten LLVM so the whole LLVM thing
was kind of hot maybe six months ago and
yeah that's kind of fallen off the spark
plan so of course all this stuff speeds
up CPU bound workloads not necessarily
i/o bound workloads
yeah I mentioned vectorization that's
basically piling as much data in as
possible not doing it per record kind of
thing right
it's SPARC $12.99 - yeah as all the gory
details there yeah so vectorization is
basically the like optimization that's
the fallback if they can't do the whole
stage fusing this is sort of like how
Park Hae works right where you smash in
all the like column values together so
you seek once this is in memory right so
this is good stuff because the same way
that like Parque and storing columnar on
disk where I like let's you seek once
and then which is the slow operation and
then scan it's the same way with memory
I mean it
not that it's not as noticeable but like
you're still able to do prefetching
right the CPU can pull in a bunch of
data can really add up all those values
and not pull in this row right like push
these out of the we're like l1 cache
pull that one in push you know prefetch
all this yeah there's a lot of wasted
prefetching happening there versus the
columnar format there's all specific to
analytics workloads right okay finally
spark - oh yeah all models and pipelines
can now be saved and loaded the one
thing I really realized quickly is that
I think this code is all buried within
the actual spark models themselves so
you can't actually overload and say save
it as JSON or save as text file
it's just parquet it's just the format
that right like data bricks has chosen
and yeah that's all you get so that's a
little bit wonky but yes I'll show some
like techniques to get around that spark
39 44 and 14 and 615 yeah man that's
crazy Mike yeah my first contribution
was spark 1982 I think yeah that's my
sister's birthday that's why I remember
that yeah so okay so these describe an
actual drop-in replacement for so right
now all distributed linear algebra or
yes all linear algebra operations within
spark all rally vector multiplies or I
like dot products things like that are
all distributed right which is why spark
is so popular because it can break up
these matrices into blocks and then
we're like do right like the math and
then pull everything together so that's
not necessarily good from the serving
write the model serving the like
prediction layer where you don't want to
be spinning up a spark job to just do
one prediction and then right yeah to
just do one dot product and then return
so they actually use the same packaging
if you look at the actual library itself
its ml Lib - local where like dot jar
that's the actual jar file Dave
right yes you can swap that in and then
do all local linear algebra yes I
wouldn't pass anything I like too big
because then it just can take a long
time but it's really the exact same
packaging and everything so yeah this
opens up the door to you right like my
new cut my yes this is flux capacitors
first product which is pipeline I oh
it's the prediction layer so actually
taking yeah so picture you write like
build a whole decision tree save it out
right like what do you do with it now so
yeah I can take in that parque and then
rarely productionize it basically yeah
so each model becomes its own docker
image and then I can scale that out like
crazy right put it behind a load
balancer and then serve up predictions
from that model okay yeah so I'll show
an example that later too
Kafka v10 Kafka streams are finally here
this is in the spark streaming storm
sort of realm right just picture a
little yes if you picture sort of like
lambdas in the Amazon world but not
shitty so it's like little yes I
shouldn't said I've never actually used
them but yes I just read like a blog
post how they're shitty so I'm just
perpetuating right like rumors so but
yeah picture little nuggets of code
where you can do joins you can do things
like that
finally Rayleigh Kafka 10 has this
notion of an event the time it was
created right which just cracked me up
because like why hasn't this been there
since like day one of you know Kafka
this is like messaging framework it's a
relic an event-driven framework this
seems like this should have been there
finally there's really crack awareness
oh hello hello hello just gets it's
getting too hot or something yeah so
rock awareness picture Netflix right
they have a bazillion Amazon instances
at like any given point in time they
need to make sure that the replicas for
their topics and for their partitions
within Kafka right so topic is like a
queue and then partitions just a small
section of that queue that's spread out
and there's replicas at the partition
level so Riley before Kafka 10 these
things could be anywhere
right so there was no rack awareness
there was no data center awareness no
right like sense of a region things like
that right like an Amazon region so if a
whole DC goes down like a whole AZ in
where like AWS terms goes down you could
potentially lose an entire like all
three replicas of your Riley Kafka right
like topic so yeah we can thank Netflix
for those contributions
yeah that's their stock sumo please yeah
please buy their stock for no other
reason and so you had my portfolio a
little bit actually I'm not a
shareholder
sold everything while I go okay Kerberos
yeah
Kerberos sazzle stuff I can look into
that on your own yeah this is kind of
cool too you can actually pause a
connector which I didn't really think
about like why this is valuable but like
during maintenance you can basically
stop pulling so the connector is
actually you know pulling from kafka
basically halt it yeah I'm gonna upgrade
myself and then
rarely continue on max pull records to
this actually would come up quite a bit
especially in the spark world where you
didn't really write like you couldn't
limit how many records you were pulling
so they would just be arbitrarily just
write like depending on whatever cupcake
gave you at that moment so now you can
actually cap it out let's see yeah
connectors this is the first time to
that you see confluent to actually have
a rarely commercial paid product it's
called control center
kind of reminds me of like data stacks
with their what's called Deena stacks
enterprise where it has a nice gooey and
all that kind of stuff right I think
there's like a free 30-day trial blah
blah blah okay so here's what we were
talking about before CUDA see you DNN
version 5 has better or wait this is the
first time that it has the really oh
yeah I didn't realize that yes I thought
oh yeah I thought this was just like an
improved version of it okay yeah so
that's pretty cool
optimized for the NVIDIA Pascal we're
like so the new GPU architecture which
has right the floating-point 16 so the
low precision what you'll see too and I
think rightly for be CEO or like someone
will talk about this but the actual
we're like the ability to train at full
precision you know 64-bit 32-bit rightly
higher precision but then go through and
then for small devices and things like
that or for like faster scoring and
classification if you can actually get
down to lower precision so this is
approximations upon where I like the
original train model I think right these
models go down lied like a third right
so now you can fit something that was
right like three hundred Meg's and is
like now down to 100 Meg's can fit on
advice they spend a lot of time right
like optimizing 3x3 convolution
specifically yeah it does anyone know
right like you know why they actually
focused on because it's the most common
okay
Boop one second
yeah the HDMI port is the only port that
actually works on my machine yeah guys
this is Roger by the way Yeah right like
has everyone seen him at pretty much
every meetup ever with this little setup
there yeah he's my official camera
person yes I see errors on your screen
sometimes someone texts you and it like
blows up or you know getting like hits
from OkCupid and match.com I see it yeah
I don't think I don't notice okay so if
you guys have been like coming to this
for a while like you know this is sort
of my reference app that I used to do a
lot of demos the flux capacitor pipeline
this was the original it started off as
a dating site the creepy spark after
dark and that come on baby
Lou it switched to green all right so
we're at Green is there like a charger
for these things okay got it
yeah so and then from like meet up to
meet up I realize I don't really do a
good job of telling you guys what I put
in since the last Meetup so this isn't
actually from you know I can't remember
what I actually put in since let but
this is the sort of hotter things that
were on my mind recently yeah has anyone
used Jupiter hub this is the greatest
thing in the world this is like taking
over it's pretty cool gives you
multi-tenant where like jupiter
notebooks so you're not you know
clobbering each other it's built into
Linux security you know has all kinds of
like security plugins the one downside
is it's Python 3 only so I sort of
forced myself to upgrade to Python 3 for
some of the examples it's pretty cool if
you're if you're building a hosted
service yeah this is what you want to
start with I attempted the SPARC Redis
connector I couldn't get it to work
so I'm working with the Redis guys right
now yes it's like one of those classic
times and I didn't realize I was doing
this but I just went on so there github
and said guys this doesn't work and
they're like okay like we get some stack
traces and yeah I mean I was already
like three like you know problems past
that so I have to go back and reinstall
the connector and figure out what the
issues were of it
yeah edit Theano so as part of the
pipeline IO stuff the flux capacitor
stuff will be supporting right like
Theano models cafe models right like
basically the ability you can push us
any model and we'll deploy it
well rally docker eyes it and scale it
out for you
caris yes I discovered Karis recently
people kept telling me about this and I
would google it you know thinking it was
like carrot like I didn't understand the
word that they were saying it finally
had someone spelled to me realize okay
yeah this is yeah it was actually pretty
cool
it's a higher-level library that you
write - yes I should probably up and say
that like tensorflow Theano are very
very low-level you actually have to
create the sessions you have to build up
these comp you know you have to do a lot
of Hoops and things like that it's super
flexible but for you know like the 80 85
percent of the time all you want to do
is just just do where like image
classification or really image training
things like that so yeah Kara so you can
write to that API it was piano only
they and they just really are not just
released but yeah they've had tensorflow
out for a while now so you can just plug
in a different back-end I think there's
another project called TF learn that's
kind of the same thing where like
tensorflow learn okay and then code wise
I spent one year building this well
actually no that's the that's this one
actually I flipped the order this is
code that actually takes the park' saved
sparked ml right so if you build a
decision tree with a pipeline and
everything where like dump it out spark
a so this actually pulls that in from
Parque goes through and builds an
optimized POJO just a plain old java
object with just a big Asif statement
right and it's if this decision point
that decision point boom-boom so this is
what actually gets deployed gets docker
eyes gets you know pushed out and scaled
out this is using Jeanine oh the same
thing that is right like powers the
whole stage code Jen where it's taking
in source code and then generating
bytecode hot-swappable
yeah so I have code out there that
within a single JVM is yeah so right now
just watching on a file system and yes
anytime a new model a new version of the
model comes up it will swap it out and
start serving that model yeah and
similarly you can actually go back to
where like older versions as well so the
start of that yeah made it into like the
latest looks the relic flux capacitor
pipeline stuff there's an eigen based
image recommendation so again back to
the creepy dating site yeah that's
always in the back of my head where if
you have so we're like the use case here
would be yes on tinder right so you're
like swiping swiping swiping if you
swipe left on tinder that's no you don't
like the person if you swipe right
that's a yes so at some point your thumb
gets tired and you can't swipe anymore
so right after about 150
swipes positive that's enough to
actually train this right like what's
called eigen face where you can take all
those images right like simplify them
down scale them down and then run PCA so
you find the principal components of
each image yes I have a full demo of
this too that I can show and then from
yeah so from this point on each new
image that comes in it can basically
auto swipe for you
so it'll it's gonna decompose that that
like image and then compare it if it's
within a particular tolerance and it's
white yeah so you can build a whole
dashboard and or like wake up in the
morning and yeah check out
yeah these dating sites man I'm telling
you people think I'm weird but there's
there's a whole ton of stuff going on
there well like one other example to I
couldn't figure out this one where like
girls email got right like bounced up
got like prioritize above other people's
emails which I only got like two emails
that whole week so it wasn't it was just
either you know Bradley email to or
email one she got bumped up to number
one and I looked at why it was really
purposely flagged right like not just it
it just wasn't time-based it was based
on the words that were in there where
like she actually made reference to my
profile like things that were in my
profile like similar things like
Sonicare I have two sonic errors because
I'm too lazy to from the shower yeah I
like brush my teeth in the shower yes I
don't want to get out and get the floor
wet to get my thing and then you know
forget and just leave it in there and so
yeah Plus Costco sell them in pairs so
you had to find a reason for that
yeah so she actually mentioned Sonicare
she mentioned Chicago right like some
other things that were in my profile so
I'm like that's pretty easy that just
matching up or I like engrams and things
like that yes also as part of this
prediction service rarely pipeline IO
stuff where we're serving up and then
deploying models yeah I'm eating hystrix
which is a circuit breaker by Netflix
this is a pretty famous architectural
pattern where if you have dependent
services that yeah so say that I'm an
edge service that's talking to like
devices talk to me and then I talked to
write like tons of other sort
is on right like behind the firewall if
some of those services go down or become
latent that circuit is gonna trip really
open up and then yes that does two
things that starts to return fall back
so you're forced to put in a fallback
which for the Netflix case would be
great like top 10 movies from the week
just sort of non-personalized
but yeah and then secondly it helps the
right like that dependent service it
right like sheds the load so that that
service can then recover or someone can
really figure out that it's down and
then bow and sewed or whatever FB so the
well a common use case there was when
like Netflix for example right so our
group is on the edge the streaming edge
so each device whenever you press play
things like that it would call in to us
and then we depending on the actual
recommendation service to we're like
serve up like the next five movies that
they should be watching whatever or the
like next in the series if that service
went down or say that or like our
service scaled up super quickly because
it was the Oscars or like something
happened and we would forget to really
physically just forget to send them an
email that we were scaling up and then
yeah we would just pound their service
so yeah that's where that would come
into play
okay quick note on the neural network
landscape so yeah this is all the rage
right now but yeah just to remind you
guys there's things like deep learning
for Jay which I think pretty much or
like everyone here has at least heard of
because it's rarely being developed here
in San Francisco
yeah there's MX net cafe right like
these have been around for a while yeah
there's Karis kera s in case you didn't
put that together yeah no I know nothing
about this because it has the Microsoft
logo but yeah like you know about this
right for Riccio c ng k yeah you
mentioned it the other day okay yeah
yeah he knows enough to stay away yeah
so that was his words not mine and torch
so torches the one from Facebook that's
written in Lua or something yeah so good
luck with that okay this is sort of the
random part of my talk here but this is
a pretty interesting use case yeah I was
at strata I think earlier in the year
yeah 2016 and they yeah so stitch fix
have you guys heard of this company
right does anyone use stitch fix come on
Roger yeah this right it's a really cool
office they have clothes everywhere and
they have a really good Meetup well it's
kind of a smaller meetup space but they
use yeah so separate from rattling
neural networks they use tons of ml so
the company there's a human stylist that
helps you pick out clothes they send you
five things and I think they have a male
version now - and so the stylist that
works for stitch fix they're the ones
that actually get the recommendations
from the Machine right from the other
machine and then they choose the five
that because of their relationship with
the person it's right like whatever they
think so this this causes a slight
problem in that the feedback loop right
like they recommend the typical
recommendation collaborative filtering
the feedback loop has this right
in the middle that that sort of screws
things up it's more personalized it's
just it's a little bit more difficult to
reason through but yeah they use ml for
that they use ml yeah so that would be
collaborative filtering shown to the
stylist and then they use we're like NLP
when you if you send something back
you're forced to say why and so they can
then really start to associate terms
with we're like negative things and
right like when you start you say
whether or not you like things off the
shoulder right like whatever really
women do yeah I don't really understand
what is fashion but but now this is cool
here so this is so this is using neural
networks taking popular items that
they've been selling right so running
them through each yes each neuron each
layer picks up different features right
and then just sort of skew it right like
change things around change the number
of right these hidden layers change the
size of these layers and then output
right like different styles so this one
has sleeves in there this one doesn't
you know stripes going one way or like
checker patterns they send this back to
the actual people that that make the
clothes what's the term for that the
seam seamstress what's the term for it
yeah yeah Taylor I guess this
mass-produced they send it back to Gap
yeah let's say yeah they're a local
company and then they can start to
decide and then figure out maybe we
should be making styles like this super
cool right all right bonus slide this is
where I can't figure out where to put
the slide so I just call it a bonus
slide gpus I'm super excited I'm going
not next week but the week after for a
four-day CUDA early GPU training class
which like is just blowing my mind
because yeah these GPUs are pretty crazy
so typical CPU you have all your
different caches things like that you
have a small set of a I'll use so here's
your GPU it's all Al you use basically
it's just doing math
so that's great if you have a lot of
math to run through these things so
let's say now that you're branching so
let's take this piece of code and that's
the blue section here so now these are
all the cores right so these are all
threads yeah so with GPUs there there's
crazy amount of cores right they have
like 4096 cores SuperDuper lightweight
threats right the like switching costs
are like super small for these thread
for these thread context switches the
right like downside is that if you do
any branching these cores stay idle so
they can only run the exact same
instruction at at at each each
instruction there yeah all threads have
to run the same so if there's a branch
and these guys stay idle so that's here
we go back to the other branch now it
flips and now these guys stay stay idle
and these guys are executing and then
back to where like all of them executing
right
did anyone yeah I didn't know this is
this new info trying to went did yeah
did everyone know this sounds like a
disaster for sure
okay tensor for landscape I'm just gonna
throw out a few names and then hand it
over to the experts here tensorflow core
so this is where you'll hear about
sessions and right like all the
low-level fine details distributed
tensorflow this was the new component
that came out a few months after the
original so yeah for breach is gonna
talk about that Sam's gonna talk about
tensor flow core probably best practices
hidden gems things like that
so what distributed you can actually mix
CPUs with GPUs and right it'll basically
figure out which which ones are the and
there's this like super complex
scheduling like piece of code where it's
running little mini simulations right
like before it actually right like
before tensorflow figures out where it
should be placing that right like
workload and then figuring out Riley
based on the overall based on what's
available at that moment which cpus are
available which GPUs are available how
long would it take for me to transfer
the memory from the CPU to the GPU yes I
didn't mention that before but CPUs and
GPUs do not share memory so to get
memory from one to the other has to go
across PCIe bus there's this fairly
newish protocol by the Nvidia guys
that's called envy link and that's an
actual like electronic protocol down at
the hardware level right now it's just
GPU to GPU but yes I believe it's like
IBM that's working with and it's
specific to the power series the IBM
power series where they're actually
building that same Riley connector
between the power CPU and right like the
NVIDIA GPUs and I think that'll be
available sometime next year I think
tensor board this is a way to sort of
visualize right like what you do is
during the training process turn on
logging and then you have control over
how often it's going to write things out
certain you know times that you want
certain conditions where you want these
logs to get written and then tensive
work can go and then visualize it where
like down to the level of like seeing
how much error or like things like that
so this way you can change your hyper
parameters and then rerun it and then
compare tensor flow playground is this
sort of fun little toy yeah I call it
it's not really related to your models
it's just a way to sort of simulate
right like neural networks and and see
which neurons are picking up which
features and you know change the
activation functions that are in each
each neuron you know from right like
sigmoid activation to like the
hyperbolic tangent things like that
SK flow this is really cool so this is
where you know that within right like
Google they've needed this right they
have code written scikit-learn or they
they want people who are familiar with
scikit-learn to start using this tensor
flow back-end so this is called sk flow
basically drop in a replacement not all
of the algorithms are implemented from
psycheon
but yeah I mean I tried it out it's like
literally take out your logistic
regression
put in the tensorflow logistic
regression and boom it's like the same
exact API
caris we talked about and then this new
project showed up recently called models
it's within the tensor flow where like
github project and it's basically where
things like the imagenet model right
like the lace the right like latest
checkpoints so things that basically
take a long time to train they've just
all right like built them then pushed
them out so now you can just from github
pull them down and do your image
classification tensorflow serving I'll
probably wait and do my demos towards
the end of the whole talk but yeah
basically you can do yeah here's your
sources filesystem right now that's kind
of the reference you would when you
build a new model you would version it
basically plus one the old version this
runtime does the same thing that right
like the model watching can see that
there's a new model that's available
we'll swap it in it will let the old
model drain right so if there's right
like code that's already if there's data
that's already flowing through the old
model that'll drain out that new one
flips in and like even right like roll
back so I've guess so this is what I'm
basically modeling everything after on
the JVM side picture
yeah so so I just said keep an eye on my
pipeline and I oh yeah I just bought
that right like domain today and it
costs yes I'm not gonna say the number
but it cost more than my first three
Honda Civics combined I think they were
cheap I mean they were like high school
Honda Civics but yeah pretty expensive